hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to nether the game now
when we last left off I was just
starting to get the ropes to this game
and now I'm gonna try to figure out
something more substantial of what I'm
doing this seems to be like his giant
egg antic wall of containers what's that
oh I see they were trying to make it
like a fortress here and it did not work
out everyone died everyone got their
intestines eviscerated into their
eyeballs there's a monster over there
okay so I seem to be able to dispatch
them with ease with my bolo sward I
don't know if there's like so like
durability in this game if so I'm not
seeing it but so far I seem to be able
to kill these little guys not so
alrights two of them
that one's dummy hey you [ __ ]
that's right get out of here that one is
just deaf and dumb high level 5 yeah
buddy come here I'm not even gonna waste
time bring it on scree me bastards
shuang oh my god okay that one actually
hurt wow what are you okay then maybe
this was a bad idea okay I'm starting to
think this is a bad idea getting out my
shotgun
hoo you [ __ ] oh my god what did I do
good god there's too many of you reload
oh my god this is a poor oh the worst
decision I've ever made my entire life
[Music]
oh god take some pills or something
hold on the pills where did they all
come from it was ridiculous it was like
20 minutes of nothing and then all of a
sudden when I decide to be a little
proactive eight I'll come out of nowhere
that was horrible I should have run I
should have run I don't get to keep
anything from it ah this is baloney Oh
fine here we go again you guys knew that
it was gonna happen I was gonna die
obviously probably lose my first
character just like that do that I
sincerely I'm not trying to die it just
happened
stop looking at me like that Hey stop -
yeah I hear you judging me
I don't need your judgments I judge
myself harshly enough then I'm gonna run
into like players that are gonna kill me
this is the episode where everything
goes wrong that's probably the name of
this episode everything goes wrong
another surge has in Oh was that what I
was experiencing whoa I was experiencing
like another surge f-off insect
repellant very funny soap all right I
guess you get a little stanky during the
apocalypse whoa I think I hit the mother
lode or something cuz I'm finding lots
of stuff chewing gum oh yeah hope I
don't know what anyway this is for can I
like use some of this stuff and we with
that sweet-ass [ __ ] machete going on
here hot damn not bad okay this'll help
I guess maybe I should level up some
more so I can die
how do I get into you I think what
happened is like I approached I must
have approached whatever the hell that
nether surge was I probably stumbled
right into it because I'm an idiot every
other player was like looking from a
distance like look at this play there's
a soul down here please what do they
mean we mean Reaper survived that was
the thing he said the thing like in the
last episode you said something about a
Reaper and now Reaper survived what does
that mean you're not being very explain
ative game game can you please tell me
more about what's going on
anything No okay I'm left to figure this
out on my own I'm recording these
sequentially so if there's something
that you guys are trying to tell me I'm
not gonna see it during these
playthroughs but I'm gonna play like
three four episodes and then then see
what you guys think about it okay lots
of food I don't know what's going on I'm
finding a lot more items dolls done I'm
just knowing where to look
subconsciously maybe my inner proneness
is finally coming out what is with that
that was like a Frick damn dingdong
Dingle barricade I couldn't think of a
word and my brain like stop for a few
seconds my brain normally runs like very
slowly and still thinking of words and
things to say does not come naturally
for me okay these security measures
would work a lot better if your front
door wasn't wide open not telling you
how to run your thing but oh I'm
entering oh I get it
that's what it said the safe zone
secured meaning that the warned any oh I
get it I get it I get it so before when
I wasn't finding any zom zoms or
whatever those mutant bastards were I
was in the safe zone the entire time
which meant that there was probably
minimal to nothing and then when I found
all the others I probably ran smack-dab
into a nest of them and if I had killed
them all I would have secured it but I
was too stupid
didn't even bandage myself up after
falling off a roof what kind of [ __ ] am
i I don't think there's gonna be any
supplies in there are they
you think but I mean I'm guessing that
this game wants to encourage me to
forage I mean this oh oh oh no that was
just done late okay you know no there's
not gonna be anything in here I don't
think going him can this axe this
Dingley dang axe here stop wibbly-wobbly
and in the corner my screen
that's awfully disconcerting did I get
anything else equipped I can't even I
can't even do anything about I'm gonna
cook the knife just because gosh dingus
doesn't Lisa doesn't go crazy off in the
corner over there okay anyway so I'm
gonna leave the safe zone ooh that looks
new hey Julia Julia do you get up on you
don't see anything let me get up on you
it would be really bad if this game
tapped into my microphone Emily Oh
oh my where do you go oh I see you okay
so this game is very strict about zones
where'd it go oh hi come here you know
do you run away from me where do you go
there you go I guess he doesn't want to
play well ok stop digging with me here
I'd really rather you not do any of that
ok ok oh hey buddy come on you want some
I got an axe with your name on it
already you gotten like two hits with
what them Wow
dammit seriously those Bologna that's
Bologna what what is what is going on
here these [ __ ] just like tougher
for some reason I need a gun that's what
I need that's probably why I got cocky
cuz I killed him so easily with a gun
and all of a sudden I thought that I'm
like oh I'm the greatest ever hang on
let me let me see something here there
was character
I leveled up ergo I should have come off
my leg
no oh there we go okay whoa what is that
blocking oh cool oh cool okay all right
I'm getting it all right I was hoping to
find out that this game would be a
little deeper than I thought it was
gotten twice
keep sneaking up on me this axe is suck
come here come here you acts like a sass
the big of a yes the crunchy that
doesn't help my health damn it I had so
many first-aid stuff last done and now
I'm not seeing a Dingle dangle good game
if you could help me out a love of judy
device rooty tooty a man shootie of any
sort anything would help I found like 10
per julien guns I get back gosh damn it
stop that how do I block oh that's how I
block okay so now I have the ability to
block at least block you block you I'm
off I'm off I'm gonna die again sad
alone in the apocalypse art oh no I
gonna I'm not gonna I'm gonna go to high
ground screw this
I was always safer at the high ground
job lady man
oh I'm not safe Emma hey of a stop nice
to leave me alone how about you go away
so that I can live another day
Oh does that think all other monsters
oh Jesus where'd you come from
nope now no block I block you tosser
I'll screw this I'm running I'm running
I'm learning for my lesson I'm running
I'm running oh where am I ring oh I'm
gonna die again going I'm going I'm
going
who are you guys are you guys oh no i'm
bony hambone okay I'm just gonna back up
slowly swing my oh god I'm really gonna
wow going wrong oh you are creepy
oh ah where'd you come from
I had soap an F off insect repellent
damn it this is hard that's what she
said ah really hard you don't keep
anything from your characters they're
gonna be a lot more careful on this I'm
not doing well what's with the money
what do I do with the money's there like
a store I don't know I'm not doing well
not doing well died I am bad at this
game I am bad don't judge me I'm very
bad okay alright let's just take this
nice and easy now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna be very careful and I'm gonna
try I don't know if this is like all
City or what but I'm not gonna fight
anyone that is like the last thing on my
list unless I have a gun I'm not gonna
fight anyone because holy hell this game
is rather difficult uh-huh my stress
levels are elevating because I don't do
well with situations like this okay
there's a church maybe I can find
salvation
no keeping my ears open my oh I see you
okay there a way to let go okay yeah
there's a way to go prone okay see you
what is that like that bar is that my
heart rate or what they're like a noise
level cuz it was a noise level in Daisy
[Applause]
I'm not sprinting I don't want to I'm
sincerely sincerely gonna try to survive
from now on if I die it will be a
sincere tragedy okay everybody just take
a nice deep breath relax in through the
nose out through the mouth it's good for
ya I'll relieve tension relaxes your
muscles this is a stressful game admit
okay so some sort of highway this too
old god those are people those are
people I'm gonna go say hi to the people
hey guys hi I'm trying to survive I'm
gonna help you I'm gonna help you hey
guys I'm gonna help you I'm gonna help
you hi hi there hi I'm helping look at
me look at me help look at me help hi
I'm helping don't kill me I'm helping
I'm gonna help out
yeah yeah teamwork team you guys are
awesome or your name's mr. mcjiblets &
Mersey Juden hi hi hi hi Oh Kelly Brett
I'm dancing you're dancing you're people
I'm but totally friendly oh god okay
let's do this alright I've found friends
who didn't kill me right off the bat I
think we're gonna be okay unless they
stab me I'm gonna call you Smitty and
I'm gonna call you begin yeah yeah okay
so uh what do we do Smitty and build
real tell me lead meteor please leave me
what are you talking about you
discussing something over there are you
gonna betray me okay good all right
you're not gonna betray me just yeah
we're gonna live together as friends
best of where you go okay I've been
following I'm up [ __ ] okay rule all the
earth your Smitty wait are you your
Bravo Guzman and you're Smitty I'm
a-comin we're gonna live okay good there
we go got it yeah we're good all right
watch where you're swinging there okay I
can't believe I'm tired these guys as if
they can hear me you are not number one
they're my friends
I knew they would stab me in the back
I'll just have to stab them in the back
I'll stab them in the butt that's what
I'll do
I'm gonna get them if I find a gun in
this house you're gonna get it oh my god
I'm gonna getcha Smitty ah good job
where'd you go stick with me I'm gonna
mess with you hell yeah don't you run
away from Mark Blair don't you run away
from me
oh you slashed at me before but now I'm
pretty shocked you live with my shame
hey they attacked me first it's their
bad luck that they just happened to dump
me where I was gonna find a frickin
assault rifle whose fault is it whose
fault is it whose fault is it
what [ __ ] I look like I look like a jerk
don't I look like a jerk
Daisy has corrupted me but I tried you
you all saw I tried to I tried to
coopera I was I was I was being friendly
I was being open
I was not attacking them I was being
delightful conversationalist I was a
good host and then they attacked me
that's how that went down that's how
that happened
okay everyone good good okay we're all
in agreement right
good good good okay I'm just gonna hide
in this corner all right I'm all out of
time for this one oh I actually am I'm
really enjoying this damn this is
actually really intense and stuff so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]